on la boulangerie de la rue ménilmontant
j'ai dans la vitrine repéré de
beaucroissant faudrait 4 chocolatines ou
et pour emporter et les trois croissants
tous les dimanches matins fait sadoun
vient humer l'odeur d'un pays qui lui
manque
au delà de mon enfance c'est c'est
l'odeur de la france qui est là et puis
le la nostalgie le de la france et puis
l'amour qu'on a de la france aussi
évoqué dans d'autres choses comme ça
mais cette douce france a pris ces
dernières années un goût amer pour des
gens comme cred et sa famille
je suis juif hockey et avec mon épouse
on avait des jeunes enfants et on a
estimé que la france était plus un pays
pour le dans le canon on se sentait
suffisamment en sécurité
oh et puis quand on regarde les
perspectives pour faire grandir nos
enfants
depuis quelques années le nombre
d'incidents ces mythes augmente de façon
exponentielle en france en 2014
851 car sans ces agressions vandalisme
injures
c'est deux fois plus qu'en 2013 ce que
les français appellent le nouvel
antisémitisme et qui concentraient dans
son issue de l'immigration arabo
musulmane lorsqu'on était arrivé ici
avec mon fils petit il avait 8 ans
sortait de la synagogue et on avait la
kippa sur la tête
il me dit papa papa on à la kippa sur la
tête vite il faut l'enlever et julie non
non non pas besoin on est au canada
est ce que le québec est un havre de
paix pour les juifs
c'est comme ça que le voient moi c'est
vraiment comme ça je le vois on peut
arriver être tranquille faire sa vie
vivre ce qu'on est
et puis sans se sentir ni menacer ni
juger
devant les écoliers il ya la police qui
surveille dans les rues de paris
on a vu des gens défiler en prononçant
mort aux juifs c'est pas arrivé depuis
effectivement 70 ans donc c'est plus la
somme de ce petit antisémitisme au
quotidien qui crée déjà ce climat
généralisé de doute sur l'avenir d'ee
d'autres qui se traduisent concrètement
par des départs à jérusalem 2 my mom
travaillent pour le gouvernement
israélien
sur un plan d'accueil des gîtes de
france en israël on a eu mille sept cent
il ya deux ans trois milieux 3800 l'an
dernier puis en 2014 on était déjà à
7000 personnes donc sa double chaque
année donc on attend au moins 15000
cette année même si l'état d'israël ne
ferait rien
l'an dernier le canada a accueilli près
de 6000 français il est impossible de
dire combien de juifs parmi eux
puisqu'on ne demande pas aux immigrants
leur religion tune urbaine j'aime la
ville donc j'ai besoin d'être ici pour
voir où j'habite pour sentir sentir ma
ville et puis c'est bof quoi là on voit
toutes voies tout quoi j'adore mais une
chose est certaine la communauté juive
de montréal entend de plus en plus
l'accent des juifs de france dans ses
rangs déjà ces francophones
il ya aussi des juifs qui partent aux
états unis mais montréal reste une
destination de choix est juif au québec
écoutez moi je vous parle à la caméra
j'ai pas je suis pas inquiète de parler
à la caméra dire que et tout le monde
nous aime ici bah c'est sûr qu'il ya des
gens il ya des petits des petites
anecdotes antisémites à droite à gauche
mais de là de dire qu'il ya un vrai
sentiment antisémite au québec n'ont
certainement pas depuis l'attentât du 9
janvier dernier dans une huile de paris
les services à l'immigration de la
communauté juive de montréal ont reçu
des dizaines de demandes des deux juifs
français
je sais pas pourquoi j'entends de toutes
parts tout autour de moi canada
on n'a plus rien à faire en france le
frère de fred
franck veut lui aussi partir vers le
froid pendant l'impression que
l'amérique du nord
alors le canada en l'occurrence c'est un
espèce c'est une espèce d'el dorado de
nouvel eldorado
montréal un nouvel eldorado peut-être
pas mais certainement un endroit où le
seul obstacle pour se rendre à la
synagogue c'est la neige et le froid